in this season of giving one Colorado
couple never expected that donating
their old Christmas tree would lead to a
heartwarming annual tradition more than
two thousand trees later the Christmas
tree project is still going strong
Barry Peterson has the story
moms dads and kids lined up on a cold
Colorado morning for something to warm
their holiday a free Christmas tree for
most caught in tough economic
circumstances this would be the only way
to have a tree six year old Daniel and
his four year old brother Michael
there's plenty of opinions you want that
one okay make sure you tell your mom and
dad
the trees were donated each family got
one hook them upstairs into a Christmas
wonderland of donated ornaments and
decorations rooms with everything needed
to turn a tree into a home's Christmas
centerpiece all organized by David and
Michelle fine and all started with a
one-line ad on Craigslist eight
Christmases ago we bought a new
Christmas tree we were talking we said
what are gonna do with our old tree and
we said what does give it away in
Craigslist so we put a one-line ad on
Craigslist that simply said free
Christmas tree to a family with children
and we got 20 responses in an hour
wounded vets single moms people that
were struggling one of the first to
respond to that ad was Feliz liquori she
heads up Rocky Mountain kids a
non-profit their houses children and
teens in the foster system
david has provided Rocky Mountain kids
Christmas trees since 2010 in every one
of our five homes I just need to call
David we need a tree we opened a new
home BAM he's got me a tree 17 year old
Alexis thinks the tree changes life in a
foster system group home they try to
make you feel like family and like it's
a normal Christmas so we're gonna have a
tree we're gonna have stockings we're
just going to enjoy it like a normal
family
the fines estimate they've given away
more than two thousand trees over the
years it's like the true Christmas
spirit shows up on both sides and for a
moment you know people realize the
beauty of giving the beauty and the the
humbleness of having to ask and all of
that sort of coming
[Music]
and Michelle's granddaughter she's one
of the youngest helpers 10 year-old rose
[Music]
I direct the kids to the toys and do the
kids like that how come because they
like their faces light up with joy
amazingly all of this will be gone by
Christmas that's a lot of smiles on the
faces of a lot of kids Michael and
Daniel sister heaven mom Amanda and dad
Richard took their time there wasn't fun
a lot to choose from I donate baby stuff
as she grows out of it and I saw an ad
for this free Christmas tree
organization and I signed up for it
through the kids and is there gonna help
you have a better Christmas yes
good job give me five there seems to be
a sense that you creative of dignity
it's a gift it's not a handout why is it
you want that sense I want them to feel
an experience of abundance and being
taken care of and an ease in their lives
an experience of being cared about and
really seen as a person a valuable
person and not just another person who
wants something for nothing for Amanda
and Richard and the family their tree
now had a home and a lot of decorations
thanks to the kindness of strangers
it really was beginning to look a lot
like Christmas perfect
for CBS this morning Saturday Barry
Petersen Colorado Springs that story
warms your heart yeah no thanks to David
and Michelle fine for 2000 Christmas
trees now doing great work yeah really
are